all right we are live once again for a
reading from my
uh 2011 book
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in france
we started doing these readings back in
2021 the 10-year
anniversary and we've been doing these
now for
quite a while not quite a year but a
good amount of time
this is the
last session in all of these readings
because we've now got to
basically the
end of the book with leon noel's the
notion of christian philosophy which
i'll be
reading in just a minute
um and so
you know for those who might be tuning
in
and don't know what this is all about
this
book was a translation of a number of
documents from the 1930s christian
philosophy debates that took place
largely in france but also
involves
francophone philosophers and also other
language philosophers in other countries
and they ran from about 1931
winding down around 1936 and there's
there's good reasons why
they
basically stopped around that time but
the issue has never really gone away and
it's been reapproached a number of times
sometimes from the perspectives of the
philosophers
involved in these debates sometimes from
new perspectives sometimes from
perspectives that actually are a little
bit
less developed than those in these
debates and i make the case that
you know the issues and the the the
matters at hand have never really been
looked at as seriously and by as many
people as during these debates
the reading that i have for you here is
by this guy leon noel
and you notice as we're going through it
that he is going to be bringing in
phenomenology
there were some other
phenomenological approaches to the
problem of christian philosophy during
the debates most notably
at the
the first and second meetings of the
society thomas
de philosophie
in 1930
and 1933
and
noelle is
doing something quite interesting here
this by the way as as
he notes is a presentation made at the
8th international congress of philosophy
at prague the reader will please note
that the rigorous limits imposed on the
communications by the regulations of the
congress do not allow entering into long
discussions on the other hand please
remember that in the very mixed
atmosphere of a meeting of that sort it
was necessary to explicitly raise theses
accepted as elementary and domestic and
scholastic
circles so
um oh before before we get going mark is
weighing in and saying thank you for
this translation these readings you've
made these great philosophical debates
available to so many more people
wonderful work thanks mark yeah and and
that has been that was one of the
reasons for engaging in this work of
translation which took me basically from
around
2003
to
2010
a lot of research that went into it as
well
and that was that was the hope
unfortunately pricing of the volume put
it out of the hands of many readers we
could talk about that later so let's
let's get into
the
last reading from this leon noel the
notion of christian philosophy published
in review neo-scholastic philosophy
volume 37 1934
the question of christian philosophy has
been quite forcefully debated these last
years ever since it was the object of an
interesting session at the society
frances de philosophy on 20 on the 21st
of march 1931
articles and pamphlets followed and a
new discussion on 11 september 1933 this
time at the society thomist ended up
adding a certain number of points of
view to those that had already been
raised
the question shows us two sides first
there is a historical side
in my opinion in his beautiful book the
spirit of medieval philosophy mr etienne
jose has decisively shown that in the
middle ages there is a philosophy that
developed in so far as philosophy under
christianity's determining influence and
that owes the progress it made over
greek philosophy to that influence
i do not want to enter into examining
this thesis but supposing this influence
to be a recognized fact how should it be
characterized how can christianity
exercise a determining influence on a
constitution without it ceasing by that
very fact to be a philosophy
the question can be treated
independently of history since today
there's a school of philosophy that aims
to draw inspiration from the doctrines
of medieval scholasticism
in this school's view
philosophy finds its relations with
christianity defined by thomas aquinas
formulas it accepts the same formula the
same influences to which he submitted
this school was established at any rate
in catholic settings and under the very
decisive impulsion of leo the 13th
exhortations let us therefore try to see
to what exact degree neo-scholastic
philosophy submitted to christian
influence
many times over
representatives of the neo-scholastic
school have indicated their repugnance
for the expression christian philosophy
or catholic philosophy
however for some time there have been
some who've tried to the contrary to
justify these expressions
i do not believe that this divergence of
words corresponds to a deep divergence
about the most basic level of the
question
for quite a long time these expressions
have served to mark some tendencies
fairly hostile to neo-scholasticism or
to neotomism
on the other hand those who adopt them
today experience the need to surround
them with explanations approaching very
near to the point of view of these who
reject the expressions and those
rejecting for their part do not dream of
denying the christian influence we are
currently discussing they stick only to
emphasizing that this influence does not
remove from philosophy the necessary
autonomy of its demonstrations
how do they conceive of this autonomy
in volume one of his logical
investigations mr husserol distinguishes
three
patterns of connection in the field of
science whose frameworks mix together
without being confused the pattern of
connections of those things with which
the mind is occupied the pattern of
connection of the acts by which the
subject comes to be occupied with these
objects and the pattern of connection of
ideas
the logical pattern of connection that
is the specific pattern of connection to
the theoretical ideas in which the unity
of the truths of a discipline theory or
proof of influence are constituted the
unity of concepts in a true proposition
of simple truths and truth combinations
etc
and eminently scholastic notion and one
that quickly enough clarifies our
question
in a philosophy there's an objective
pattern of connection of ideas of
propositions of reasonings which imposes
itself on the philosopher's mind
but to which precisely because it
imposes itself in this way
the philosopher recognizes or believes
to recognize an ideal consistency that
is independent in its logical being from
the adherence he gives it
this is an evidence that will impose
itself on other minds and that would
still remain what it is even if no mind
recognized it
in the structure of this pattern of
connection which objectively makes a
philosophical doctrine or reasoning be
what it is that is philosophical
there is no place at all for anything
besides objective evidences but for the
philosopher who inquires who reflects it
is a matter of discover discovering
these evidences
and this discovery takes place by very
different paths than the pattern of the
connection of ideas here are not only
frankly irrational
factors sentiments or an obscure willing
that pushes and sustains the research
but also some objective elements a fact
the speech of another that are at first
irreducible to the rational structure
the mind perceives and that later by
their presence alone cause an entire new
structure to appear with which they are
integrated but
as a consequence and not at all as a
principle
and in which sometimes they can even not
be integrated
once the objective pattern of connection
that satisfies the mind is displayed it
is independent of such factors newton's
apple does not order the technical
exposition of gravitation but without
the apple newton would not have
discovered gravitation
christian doctrines do not enter as such
into the objective exposition of a
philosophy or then that philosophy would
cease to be a philosophy
they cannot serve as such for the basis
of a reasoning but their presence in the
mind of the believer can orient the
research with a new meaning a moment
will come where the proposition at first
an object of faith
will appear as the necessary consequence
of an evident demonstration reconnected
to more prior principles that the
philosopher held solely from his
philosophy
or better yet without integrating
christian doctrine philosophy will
organize itself by leaving christian
doctrine outside of its own structure
but also by harmonizing itself with it
always
the objective construction satisfying
the mind has its own proper consistency
resting only on evidence and purely
philosophical evidence communicable to
any other mind even if it be an
unbelieving one and able to be discussed
on the common ground of certainties that
all grant
however
without the christian faith this
construction would not have been
revealed to those who now contemplate it
if we put ourselves in the viewpoint to
the coherence of the demonstration in
itself
we will insist on its perfect autonomy
and on its purely philosophical
character this will be the point of view
of the systematic philosopher for whom
there will not be any christian
philosophy
if we put ourselves in the viewpoint of
the genesis of the system
we will know to the contrary that
without christian influence the most
essential theses of the system would not
have ever been reached and that it is as
philosophy a christian philosophy this
will be the historian's point of view
for whom doctrines
are not separated from the human effort
and the living evolution that bears them
is the first point of
is the first point of view not more
rigorous and more formal as legitimate
as the second may be
it does not push the analysis as far
and the manner of speaking it involves
while correct is less strict
a philosophy
in the formal and strict sense is an
objective association of ideas whose
evidence imposes itself nothing can
enter into this association that is not
homogeneous there
we do not see how a datum of faith would
enter there in this sense quote there is
no more a christian philosophy then is
there it has been said christian physics
or chemistry or geometry
scarcely any thomas i believe will be
found who would contest that rigorously
speaking the formal object of philosophy
is an association of purely rational
ideas
but perhaps someone might judge that we
somewhat oversimplify these questions do
not concepts especially when it is a
matter of metaphysical concepts have the
consistency that we seem to lend them
do we not forget everything
everything that the endlessly renewed
life of the mind must put into the poor
words that we use to make our
demonstrations hold
doubtless the perfect clarity of a
discourse unambiguously accessible to
every intellect is less an acquired
result
than the ideal limit
towards which philosophy's effort
strives
it will aim therefore at removing from
its constructions all that would drag it
into an opposed meaning it can be that
the believer never arrives at explaining
in his demonstrations all the reasons
that his faith causes him to grasp
partially
still he strives towards that
explanation and he cannot admit that his
philosophical doctrine would be
irremediably closed to those who do not
share his beliefs
none of us can reach in the bottom of
hearts the mysterious secret of certain
divergences but at least there is in
rational thought a zone of common
clarity where we hope to reduce them
reconciliation of minds by objective
evidence
such as the hope that traverses the
famous letter a tyranny potress from one
end to the other by which leo the 13th
gave an impetus to the neo-scholastic
movement
space is lacking here for us to show
how the question there is not of a
return of philosophy to tradition but
rather of re-illumination of the purely
philosophical
and rational element contained in the
historical fact of christian philosophy
serene confidence and reason
energetic reaction against the feediasm
of the 19th century
scientific and rational progress harmony
with the sciences and modern thought
such is the spirit that my master
cardinal mercy had
extracted from that admirable document
and with which he imbued the school he
founded at louvain
but here is another problem
christian dogma the church the christian
life mystical experiences all of this
presents itself as implicated in
some visible public facts that science
and philosophy cannot ignore all of this
on the other hand is for the believer
the object of a judgment of faith which
he cannot renounce without forfeiture
in this domain at least will christian
philosophy not be incommensurable with a
purely rational philosophy
the transcendent element that is there
in christian facts presents itself to be
sure from the point of view of faith
under a positive aspect one cannot study
this aspect without subordinating one's
judgment to faith
but whatever may have been said about it
recently and interesting discussions
that would take too long to lay out
i believe that to do this would always
be doing theology
not philosophy
it is precisely where the line of
demarcation between philosophy and
theology is found that the latter admits
and the former cannot admit a datum of
positive faith into the objective
structure of its associations
there is to the contrary a negative
element to every transcendent element
its irreducibility to rational
explanation this negative aspect is
accessible negatively to philosophy
and the believer will perhaps more than
anyone else be disposed to recognize and
respect it but he is not the only one
who can do that
nothing hinders the pure philosopher
from recognizing his limitations nothing
hinders him from admitting the
possibility of a domain that escapes him
nothing obliges him assuredly to exclude
this possibility conscient critiques
grensberg finds an excellent application
here
nothing but christian facts places us in
the presence of the mystery it is
everywhere around us it is especially
and doubtless irreducibly at the basis
of our moral life
and there is a scandal for reason there
that kant once again noted in the first
part of religion within the limits of
reason alone
can a philosophy open up the mystery
that we are discover aspirations and
deficiencies that only the supernatural
can fill
necessary and inaccessible at the same
time as mr blondel showed in accio 1893
can it from that point on lead up to
faith recognizing christian dogma and
practice the response offered to
nature's and reasons requests
it is this effort opening up into
christianity
that the same author calls catholic
philosophy while insisting even more
that the thomas than the thomas on the
strict autonomy that philosophy retains
in its operations wanting to establish
between it and theology a symbiosis that
reflect respects their heterogeneity
whereas to the contrary mr mara 10
believes that philosophy will not be
able to advance itself on this ground
except by receiving principles in a
direction from theology by subordinating
itself to theology
we will not enter into this discussion
but whatever the results may be that
such a research can give
it is clear that so long as it remains
purely rational it does not place in its
construction anything that would not be
just as accessible to the unbeliever as
to the believer the expression catholic
philosophy could give the wrong
impression about mr blondel's true
thought here and it is not readily
apparent what advantage he finds in
using it
to be sure once again
it can be that the believer discovers
the elements he orders and they're very
ordering only by following the
orientations of his faith and no foreign
contribution will enter into the
association of ideas that constitute his
demonstration if mr blondel's views are
right it is philosophy itself that
from its point of view will declare
itself powerless to resolve the enigma
that we are to ourselves and it is not
asked to go beyond its own means to
affirm that there is a solution to the
enigma
it is asked only to take note that the
enigma raises itself and that it does
not resolve the enigma
after the lesson of critique would
philosophy have the pretension of
closing up the mind in a world where
everything was clear worked out and
finished
it will leave open then the doors
through which faith can pass
beyond these doors it is no longer in
its abode and the domain of theology
begins
if at times people have been able to
call this a christian philosophy
that is a way of speaking that can
engender only confusion
and with that
leo noel ends his rather short
contribution to the debate and that is
the final chapter
in the book
reason fulfilled by revelation
the final chapter of the translations
there is of course
a
bibliography of works on the christian
philosophy and their
christian philosophy debates and their
issues it goes from page 2
83 to
let's see here to two to uh 312 so
um almost a 30-page bibliography which i
had hoped would be you know helpful for
people of course it only goes up to 2011
but it does provide some really great
useful background for people who are
beginning their research in this and
i think you know while i'm waiting for
questions and comments i'm going to go
through this a little bit and mention
some of the pieces and i'll translate
the uh the the uh um french or german or
whatever into english so you know we're
we know exactly what we're talking about
but some of these pieces that i think
are
ripe for
translation and which i would you know
kind of like to get to some time so
there are some things antidating the
debates that i think would be really
good to to do to provide context going
all the way back
to um
1928
there's um
emme ferret had um auteur de la nocionde
de uh
de la philosophy cretienne in
about or around the notion of christian
philosophy you notice that in 1928
somebody's already using that term right
there
um
leon noel also has a really interesting
piece in 1929
uh the san cantim anniversary de la
lanzi clique uh itinerary patras which
would be the 50th
anniversary
of the attorney potress encyclical that
would be good to translate
1930
reggie jolievet who we haven't talked
about before has this this nice piece
called
elenism a christian
christianism so hellenism and
christianity i think that would be quite
good to do i i've mentioned before
joseph marichal has this interesting
comparative study of blondel and
phenomenology or uh philosophy of action
um
what else i mean
so you know certainly actually has a
piece in 1932. sir quelca character did
the philosophy cretienne on several
characteristics of
christian philosophy which was published
in a um
german
language piece
book rather philosophy perennis
philosophy so talking about the the
history of philosophy
a lot of the stuff from 1931
got translated but there is a really
interesting piece by uh marcel de court
sir the nocio de the philosophy
that i think would be good to to
translate reggie giovetti actually had a
couple books come out
about it as well
[Music]
there was a german language uh piece by
hermann zeltner in 1931 zurkatalicion
culture philosophy on
on
catholic culture philosophy right that
could be quite interesting
louis agro had a piece in 1932 on
christian philosophy sir the philosophy
in review apologetique
um
who else we've got eighteen borns piece
in there
um
there were there were two pieces by this
guy uh guillermo la nocion
two subsequent pieces
uh so the the notion of christian
philosophy that would be kind of good to
do um
[Music]
who else oh michelle suriyo uh
keskun philosophy chretien what is a
christian philosophy he was a protestant
and an augustinian philosopher who's
writing in the middle of the debates
1933 saw a lot of really great pieces
that we just couldn't get into the
volume like jacques boise philosophy a
religion the first part
that is philosophy and religion
um
henri goulier the great french historian
of philosophy digressions or the
philosophy
of philosophy
some digressions on philosophy in
relation to christian philosophy
sort of a typical guian
title there
andre mark had a good piece called
philosophy
you know
christian philosophy and theology
[Music]
who else
oh yeah
seger
in the review dominican ottawa has an
interesting piece as well
philosophy
meaning
christian philosophy or christian
philosophies in the plural already
raising a very important issue
in 1934 jacques wa followed up with his
philosophy religion the second part
we have andre bremons ratzinolism a
religion uh which was like quite good
and then also in 1934 we had two parts
to this um this uh
article by louis paul courche
which i think is a very good one um and
so you know in light or or taking an aim
at christian philosophy
um who else
uh abe penido who is in the society tom
east session has a piece called sir the
problem historique de la philosophic
on the historical problem of christian
philosophy
and uh yves samoa actually has a piece
um
in etude carmelitan called philosophy
cretien not complementer yves simone if
you don't know him was a very important
thomas philosopher so he's getting
involved in the debates
and then in 1935 brunchfig one of the
rationalist commentators brings out his
uh religion philosophy which is
eventually going to figure into a book
on his part leon
who may you know many of you you know i
have a great interest in brings out his
first piece of athens a jerusalem
concupiscence
erebustibilis irresistibilis
um
athens and jerusalem a
irresistible desire and that will turn
into an entire book it'll get published
in the review to metaphysical morale
there's also a pedro de [ __ ] who blondel
had had a
polemical correspondence with before who
writes a piece uh called appendice sir
the philosophy cretienne
which is
quite important as well representing the
neo-scholastic against christian
philosophy side
um reggie jo yvette a rather overlooked
author has this piece uh le fudo sofi
cretienne et bergsonism and people
sometimes ask was bergstone himself
involved in these debates he wasn't but
there were other
authors who thought that he made some
interesting contributions
we get our first latin language
as far as if my memory is correct peace
in 1936 by bernard badou
question philosophy christiana in
antonianum
that could be cool to translate too and
then the blick
publishes another one quonum
what proper sense does the
term christian philosophy
have blondel publishes another piece
that i haven't translated but i've you
know read and referenced office du
philosophy in 1936 which is quite good
um those of you who are fans of gary goo
lagrange somebody who you know that i
don't respect very much has a piece
himself uh dave relations inter philo
sophia met religion published in latin
of course
in the octa secunda congresses
domestique internacionales in 1936
which has
which could have some interest because
it's got um presentations by deblic
franc curiatus and fernandez alonso and
then garugula garage's responses
um joseon publishes some more stuff
which is all basically translated at
this point
um
and
there's another good piece
by alex renar called sir the possibility
of the phil la
phila philosophican
on the possibility of christian
philosophy and i do also want to point
out that anri de lubach
has a piece which in french is certainly
philosophy cretienne reflection of the
sweet dude and he's saying the debate is
basically done here in 1936
that has actually been translated
as retrieving the tradition on christian
philosophy you can find it published in
1992
in communio
um and so that that's an important
contribution i think to the debate as
well and he he's very good at like
connecting up
blondel joseon mara 10 also marcel and
then talking also about mock shaler in
that piece and then it just goes on from
there and you notice 1936 is the last
year where there's a lot of
discussion i mean they're approaching
world war ii people are turning to other
topics
and you know in some respects
international communications are
starting to break down as well so from
1937
all the way to
the late you know to like 1946
there's not a lot of
stuff coming out 1941 is a a year where
there's actually
five articles that fit into the debate
including one by blondelle called la
philosophy
open philosophy in a book about henry
bergson
and then it picks up again in 1947 when
debates begin in
reformed protestant circles in french
and it continues on to the present i
mean some years like uh
1966 there there's a lot of stuff uh
1961 and we could go on and on from
there um but you know that's that's kind
of an interesting thing so
um let me take some questions and
comments
mark says
um the sessions have gotten me to think
differently about my relationship with
christ and christianity i doubt if i'd
consider that philosophy though nor
theology not sure what to call it yeah
so now that is actually an important
issue
not only where do we draw the boundary
lines between things but what do we call
philosophy that is actually taking
something from
christianity like christian texts or
traditions or
uh communities and then this this figure
of christ seriously
and bringing it into philosophy can we
call it philosophy does it have to be
theology um you know
jill so actually has a really
interesting proposal when talking about
saint anselm which by the way he takes
from the early christian thinker
clement of alexandria he says
i'm not going to call it philosophy i'm
not going to call it theology i'm going
to call it christian gnosis
and
this is a different kind of thing right
i actually have an article on that that
i published years and years ago in the
saint anselm journal about saint anselm
and the christian philosophy debates
um and so that's that's kind of an
interesting issue and there is no
agreement in these debates that ever
gets quite worked out ricky says it's
been very informative it gives me some
philosophical insight in citations to my
own research well that's good because
you know the whole point
of publishing this book originally
was to try to promote
interest engagement and research on the
part of
both scholars you know like historians
of philosophy but also the broader
public that's interested in the
relationship between christianity
and philosophy and unfortunately
it didn't accomplish that because
catholic university of america press
priced this book
out of the hands or out of the interest
let's say of many readers they priced it
at 75
we know that if if a book costs more
than 50
for the american public it's probably
not going to get bought except by
libraries and a few
specialists
and
it's unfortunate and there's a vicious
cycle too will there ever be a soft
cover version of it well it has to sell
a certain number of copies and then
they'll consider a soft cover version
so if you don't sell all those copies
you're not going to get the softcover
version that would sell more copies
right
so this is a bit of a problem um
i don't know what would ever lead to
getting catholic university of america
press to you know
get get further behind it but they're
kind of like a lot of academic presses
they're not doing particularly well so
all right let's see what else we've got
um
mark says uh given that there are
contributions to the debate that you
haven't covered now that we're done
are there any notable lacuna in the
debates you were surprised weren't
addressed um
you know that's the thing so if we
actually had all of the materials
translated and at our hands
when you go through them you would see
that there there's not a lot of
lacuna
of empty spaces of places where you're
like well nobody actually talked about
this well
in the debates in part because a lot of
the ones who i haven't translated
addressed the things that would be
you know like missing in in the things
that are translated in this and in um i
mentioned you know honoree de lubeck's
article is translated
um joe song's works and mauritan's works
from the debates are also translated
so um
you know there that you know i mentioned
like pierre meidu or you know romeier or
these other people
what we're missing in these english
translated stuff is is in those those
french and latin and german things that
we um just haven't translated at this
point in time
um
all right
let's see ricky says
there's like a back and forth that's
that's going on here
um what distinguishes theology from
spirituality i mean when it comes to
these dividing lines like i pointed out
there is no consensus on that there are
many different versions of of how these
things divide themselves out from each
other but that's kind of contested
territory and it's i think it's useful
to engage in the practice of trying to
figure out where these dividing lines
would in fact um
go
understanding that you're not going to
get everybody to buy into
your own particular view on that
uh
bokoft says are you a catholic yeah i
was raised catholic left the church came
back you know i'm not particularly
devout
but i am you know i do situate myself
solidly within the uh
broad
christian philosophical tradition which
includes you know a lot of people from
the uh the catholic church also some
orthodox you know i also read a lot of
uh protestant thinkers as well
this is you know
largely an intracatholic debate
uh published by catholic university of
america press i did most of the research
for it at university at notre dame
but none of that should actually be
particularly
relevant to the the you know the
translation or the text themselves it's
not like being catholic somehow makes
you better at translating catholics or
anything like that
um
all right any other questions comments
things people would like me to talk
about we've got we've got a good bit of
time before i've got to go and get to
some other work
so you know this will be like i said the
the very last
of our digging into this oh so mark has
an interesting question is there
anything in the gospels you would
consider philosophy
sermon on the mount the debates jesus
engages in
i mean philosophy it depends on how we
define it right there's no consensus on
what counts as
philosophy and we could we could say a
similar thing about you know um
the uh
sermons attributed to the buddha or
later later buddha buddhist
scholasticism with whether therobotin or
mahayana or we could say that about
a lot of uh things or the vedas
philosophy i mean talk to indian
orthodox philosophers and they will tell
you yes but talk to you know
run-of-the-mill analytic philosophers
and they'll say are you crazy you know
none of that's philosophy so
um i would i would say less philosophy
and more sort of ripe for for being
appropriated within
philosophical traditions so think about
for example
in the sermon on the mount i know this
because i do a lot of work on anger
there there's that whole passage about
um
[Music]
if you get angry with your brother
you'll be liable to the judgment and
then there's don't call your brother a
fool a rock and then they don't take
your anger even further and um augustine
talks about this in his sermons and in
other places as does john cassian as
does
john chrysostom as do a whole bunch of
other people who are
you know arguably christian philosophers
they are taking that
and engaging in rational you know
reflection about it trying to apply it
to within the scope of our own lives
right so maybe the sermon on the mount
is not philosophy as such although it
certainly is ethical guidance
but it's it doesn't take a lot to
transform it into
um moral moral philosophy right and an
understanding of the emotions that is
also filled in by um
uh
you know drawing on on pre-christian uh
pagan philosophy i mean you don't have
augustine without not just pla plato
right and neoplatonism but also the
stoics who he talks about constantly or
aristotle or all these other thinkers um
you don't have uh um
clement of alexandria without platonism
and stoicism and a whole bunch of other
things clement of alexandria actually
considered
uh just as the you know jewish
scriptures
called by christians the old testament
were preparation for the gospel for the
jews
greek philosophy according to clement
alex of alexandria the right kinds of it
not epicureanism but stoicism and
aristotelianism and
were the preparation for the gospel for
for greeks so there's a wide range in in
there
um
daniel please write about how to be a
non-systematic catholic
i don't think i called myself
non-systematic i'm not even sure
what that would mean
but um there aren't any there aren't any
religious people who are truly
systematic anyway and there are very few
philosophers who are truly
systematic
um
in in any you know like substantive
sense i mean having a system oftentimes
just kind of like constrains you and
your system had better correspond to
reality or else it's a
pretty crappy system
uh bocof what brought me back to the
church no one single thing i mean any
any conversion this is really good
there's a really good chapter on
conversion william james the variety of
religious experience that i'm i'm
convinced is is pretty much correct
where he says that there's never just
one single thing even though you know
religious believers often will say well
the turning point for me was this
because there's always all this this
entire network working
uh
at the same time i mean a big part of it
for me was reading actual christian
philosophers and seeing that they
weren't the dummies or you know
ideologues who my professors were often
um presenting them as being you know
actually reading anselm
and reading thomas aquinas
and then you know doing so
i got to do so because i was trying to
work on my latin actually so that was a
big part of it um you know um reading
maurice blondel was very important for
me as well but i would say you know
part of it was also like spending time
with catholic colleagues and seeing that
you know maybe
they were as you know jill some points
out or mauritan points out maybe they
were in a better position to understand
certain things
and then you know you get let into it
and you go back and forth and back and
forth and you know so that was important
um fear and trembling can you talk about
garagula grange and why you're not too
keen on him because he's a shitty
scholar
um he he's and he's also
you know an ideologue who was on the
anti-modernist side in the modernist
controversy if he were around today he'd
probably be following steve bannon you
know
he'd be one of those catholic
traditionalists who really have nothing
to do with tradition garugoo lagrange
has has a good book on the spiritual
life and the rest of his stuff is pretty
mediocre and you know when he goes after
maurice blondell
um who by the way you know who who
defended maurice blondel when garagula
garage went after him and other people
went after him as being a modernist pius
the tenth himself
so you got somebody pretty hardcore
right wing saying listen dummies i'm
telling you that blondel is actually
orthodox
garagula garage admitted
that he
could not
understand blondel's writings and yet
that didn't prevent him
from
making all sorts of judgments about it
and so for me that's that's a sign of
somebody who has zero connection to or
respect for truth you know as a scholar
so
yeah i mean and anytime that i run into
people that are like super into garagula
garage and it's not about his
discussions of the spiritual life
they're always kooks
and they often are going after blondel
without themselves having red blonde l
so as soon as i see you know
being a you know a follower of garagu
lagrange the red flag goes up um and
that's just the way it is you know
um i'm sure there's some people who are
intelligent and you know devoted to
truth who who find some some useful
stuff in him
that i don't find but i'm pretty sure
they're pretty rare so
all right uh brenda it's usually a young
catholic girl usually for who i mean
um
that's not going to convert anybody um
you get converted because
you it's just like with you know
philosophical conversions or political
conversions hopefully it's not just so
opportunistic as well i want to get laid
or i want to get affection or something
like that
hopefully it's that you
think there's more truth that's being
offered and you want to pursue it you
know so that's uh that's quite important
you know
um
all right what else we got about another
15 minutes left what else do people want
to uh
chat about
anything anything else going on
otherwise
[Music]
we could end this a little bit earlier
too
um i mean i will say that
i mean i can't make any promises right
because i i do tend to over promise and
under deliver sometimes but i really
would like to translate some more
documents that that reading through this
stuff has been
quite good um
you know for reawakening that desire and
there's other things i'd like to
translate too i have a copy
well i there's i'll mention a few other
interesting translation things so
blondel has this amazing piece
that i think is very relevant in our
time
called uh patri et umanite
which means
roughly homeland and humanity and it was
written in
um
you know it was written as a
presentation to the cement social which
was a
progressive catholic group in france
that is still going on today by the way
and uh they were opposed to accion
frances the hard right proto-fascist
catholic organization in france at the
time and blondel sets out this
beautiful analysis because he sees where
things are going in terms of nationalism
and
you know
fascism raising its head he sets out
this beautiful analysis and i did
actually translate it a long time ago
the translation is in word perfect it's
in rough shape but i would like to go
back and and like fix that translation
up and do that
and then um
uh
there's this great dialogue on sin that
i i you know just happened to run across
in the journal esprit
years and years ago when i was doing
research at notre dame and i photocopied
it and it included people like
georges bataille
and
jean-paul sartre and a bunch of other
people as well and i always thought that
would be cool to translate so and then
there are some things by anselm i've got
a copy of the
day humanibus moribus or the day
similitudinibus
that i produced a while back and just
never got around to actually polishing
and publishing and then there's the
dicta anselmi so you know i i could
foresee doing some more translation work
in the
the future mark any plans to keep doing
something on a thursday at this time
i
i don't think thursdays um
i started something new which is um
this sort of
stoic philosophy and practice the basics
and i did it on a sunday and i kind of
like the ring of stoic sundays so i
might do that more than just once a
month like maybe twice a month
i did something on the cardinal virtues
and um
that might that might be good to like
revisit each of those virtues in turn
over like the next two months but i
think i would probably do that on a
sunday
um because those are usually
free and thursdays are often packed with
client appointments and stuff like that
but i don't know maybe maybe in the
summer we'll see what happens
um
[Music]
all right any other questions comments
[Music]
things people want me to address yeah
stoic sundays could be good i mean stoic
saturdays would be just as good too but
i already have a lot of events on
saturdays so
so i don't quite know about that um
[Music]
you know and if i do
do additional translations i'll say this
you know back when i was
you know working up to publication of
this
i was in a traditional academic
mindset and i was thinking well you you
publish them in a book and you get a
press to publish them and blah blah blah
blah blah right and then it'll it'll all
be good
but you know we have the internet at our
disposal um i don't
i don't know that i necessarily need to
publish them with an academic press and
jump through all the hoops and you know
i could just self-publish them or just
put them out as pdfs or something like
that i think that could be
quite easy to
to accomplish
the one thing i do have to do i got to
be careful about
is um
looking to see what is still
in copyright because
french copyright is not the same
structure as american copyright it has
to do like you know when the author died
and if they you know there's like a
special proviso if they did special
service to france then they get a couple
extra years
and things like that um so you can't
just like
publish anything you want like all the
the pieces in this i had to get
permissions
from like you know the blondel archives
or from the society frances d philosophy
or you know from whoever else would
would hold the copyright now that was 10
years ago more than 10 years ago so some
of the some of the pieces maybe have
gone out of copyright um so then i could
translate them however i want just like
i can i can translate and some stuff and
nobody's going to give me a hard time
because he's been dead
since 1109 right so
you know but when it comes to more
contemporary figures you got to be a
little bit careful with that you can't
just
publish a translation
uh as official unless you've got um
other stuff all right daniel says what
do you think of taylor de chardin is he
relevant in any form i just read the
traditionalist talking that he's a
globalist
yeah i mean
traditionalists people who call
themselves traditionalists today usually
don't have any sense of the tradition
that they belong to and globalist is
just a smear for being not us you know
or being jewish right there destro den
is an interesting guy he's he's like a
total outlier you know he didn't figure
into these debates at all
um
uh you know people who are into sherdon
are really into him i've actually
visited his grave i don't know if people
know this but
he's his grave is at the culinary
institute of america because the
culinary institute of america used to be
before it was before that that was
bought by the culinary institute of
america it was a jesuit um
monastery
or seminary right
and it's actually you know if you walk
in to the culinary you can still see the
you know admiral
gloriam dam uh mosaic right so shardon
is buried with a whole bunch of other
jesuits out in this this cemetery that
you actually have to get security to
unlock for you and then you can go and
check it out and i had a buddy a rock
and roll buddy who uh um
was super into chardan right a guy who
also studied at the angelicum and stuff
like that so i was like well let's let's
go check it out and so we went there and
interestingly there are still people
today who put like flowers and stuff at
his uh his grave
so
all right mark asked topic for uh
saturday's political theory and practice
discussion so i'm thinking about free
speech and specifically the
stepping into
uh their own pile of crap that the new
york times editorial
got into when they claimed that you know
so many people are like self-censoring
and then they
they said this
that everybody should have a right to
express themselves freely without fear
of shunning
or shaming
right
and now that is a crazy crazy claim that
many people rightfully took them to task
for and so i want to talk about that a
bit the notion that you know free speech
should be this absolute and i'm going to
bring in somebody who you know is is
often referenced when it comes to free
speech and that's john stuart mill
and his book on liberty
mill would say that
the social sanction which utilitarianism
recognizes you know we have to be
careful about how we apply that
but if i go out there and i say all
sorts of stupid things
um well then you know if other people
say man you're you're an idiot for
saying that they're exercising their
free speech too you know and i don't
think we have to like say oh no no no we
could never shame anybody i mean i think
a lot of people deserve to be shamed and
shamed over and over again until maybe
they they get the lesson that's how what
what mill calls the social sanction
works and so we're going to talk about
the difference between the government
censoring speech and corporations
censoring speech you know like media
corporations and academic stuff and you
know open open things like me commenting
on somebody on twitter i i razz our our
wisconsin politicians pretty frequently
when they post stuff that's clearly you
know ideological or untrue
so that that's that's the topic that i
have in mind um i'm sure there will be
some other aspects to it for the
political theory and practice discussion
and as usual i'll present for a bit and
then i'm sure people will weigh in
um and because it's free speech it'll
probably you know there'll probably be
quite a few people who are uh um
shooting from the hip as we say you know
and uh we'll see how it works out right
um
but it should be it should be fun
that'll be on saturday
um
uh
noon central time and by the way
we're on daylight savings time here so
if you're in other places like mark for
example is in south africa so you know
they don't do daylight savings time that
can introduce you know weird time
differences and stuff like that
all right we've got about another five
minutes anything else that people want
to
discuss address
um
bring up
get clarification on
um
rant about
whatever it may be
in the meantime i'll say uh it's been a
lot of fun you know talking about
well reading reading through and then
talking about
all the different stuff um
you know one of the things that i kind
of appreciate
rereading these translations is
how
you know what level a lot of these
writers were at both in terms of style
and in terms of like organization you
know when people say french philosophy
you know it's all this plays on words
you know and it's it's it's very
difficult to read
this is from a time before that became
the norm with you know
lacan gary dodd you know irrigaray and
all those sorts of people
engaging in that sort of writing this is
very clear
and
thoughtful
writing
i kind of wish that that you know that
had remained the norm
in terms of uh french philosophy but
unfortunately a different style took
place or took hold after world war ii
and became a new kind of norm that
people would write in accordance with
which is harder to translate too by the
way
um
this stuff is
is uh much easier to translate because
it's much clearer you know
so all right well um
i'll say thanks to everybody for tuning
in especially those of you who have been
here a number of different sessions
thanks to mark for helping with
moderation
and um you know i've got a lot of other
things going on as mark posted the
reason i owe calendar that people can
can check out the events calendar
um and i'm you know i'm sure i'll be
coming back to this this stuff sometime
down the line i'm not quite sure exactly
when i got to finish out my semester
and then i'll see what i'm going to be
doing this uh this summer but
yeah uh thanks to everybody and i will
see you
somewhere else in the interwebs